[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
what's the funniest [ __ ] you've ever
heard of on a Tuesday
my pillow
the my pillow guy gets quote unquote
rated
and the Hardee's driver are you
you can't write this [ __ ] you just you
can't even write it
like this stuff is is just batshit crazy
what what alternate reality are we
living in and then the gag goes on his
new station or whatever the [ __ ] it is I
don't know it's traitor TV streamer
I don't know and he tells the whole
story
and our great co-host Gabe Sanchez
um went and watched it so you don't have
to he went and watched it so you don't
have to
um
the guy posted the last four digits of
his social security number live on his
broadcast this is the guy
okay the my fellow Nazi Mike Lindell
the my slippers gay I don't know does he
have a my phone probably not anymore
but Mike Lindell the my fellow Nazi is
supposed to tell all of us
he's supposed he's got all this evidence
about security and cyber security yes
cyber symposiums
big meetings about how the evidence is
going to show that
it was the internet and Hugo Chavez and
a bunch of Italians and space aliens
that have Jewish space lasers from Mars
or some [ __ ]
the Chinese with their bamboo ballots I
don't know but he seems to know a lot
about security [ __ ] that he doesn't know
if he's posting the [ __ ] amendment to
his search warrant online with the last
four digits of his social security
number
whoosh whoosh I didn't post it he
[ __ ] posted it
he posted it he showed it to everyone
oh man you just the world we live in
and yesterday the big news yesterday
really is that Republicans oh guess what
doubt me doubt me Republicans want a
National Abortion ban they're coming for
your State's rights that's right they're
coming for your State's rights
to give women their bodily autonomy
which is constitutionally afforded to
them
they want to overturn that they want to
tell you what the [ __ ] you can and
cannot do with your body I've been
saying this I'm telling you this
I've been screaming it literally into
this microphone screaming it
and I say doubt me and really honestly
you you shouldn't doubt me but if you do
go get me some go get some doubt me
merch helps us out here at the podcast
store.btonymichaels.com
I say it all the time doubt me doubt
mean doubt me
so go grab your doubt me merch t-shirt
hoodie coffee mugs we also have some
stickers over there
oh my God stored at the Tony
michaels.com Lindsey Graham delivers for
the Democrats that's what this is
this is a delivery of the midterms for
the Democrats they are literally telling
everyone out loud yes we want to go much
further
nationally
it ain't about about states rights
anymore because it's not about states
rights it's about taking away your
[ __ ] rights your [ __ ] freedoms
that's what it's about
it's what it's always been about
it's it's 30 40 Years of pounding on Roe
v Wade has it been about abortions it
hasn't been about murdering babies
they're full of [ __ ] [ __ ] it's been
about one thing controlling you
what you are gonna do and what you ain't
gonna do
that's what it's about
it's what it's always been about it's
what it's always Lil's piece abouts
to Lindsey Graham and any kind of these
Maga Republicans
who's sycophant to this [ __ ] America
First fascism it's enough of this
nonsense
and you had the option you still have
the right you still have the choice to
vote
crawl over [ __ ] hot coals and sharp
shards of glass
to get to the ballot and Mark
pro-democracy candidates and not only
vote but engage in your democracy
talk to your family talk to your friends
it's now out in the open there's a
[ __ ] clip goddamn video clip
of Lindsey Graham supposedly the
remember he was the moderate
he was with the Maverick John McCain he
worked across the [ __ ] aisle
Lindsey Graham wants to have a national
van
on abortion
to tell women what they can and can't do
with their bodies their [ __ ] freedom
of medical decisions
their freedom to privacy inside a
doctor's office
the freedom to do what the [ __ ] they
want to do when it comes to their family
and their life it's about freedom and
they [ __ ] want to take it away from
you and they want to take your [ __ ]
States freedom
to make sure you have freedom
you don't think they want a fascist
State you don't think [ __ ] Ronda
Santa's blueprint down in Florida is
exactly what they're trying to implement
nationally what about Greg Abbott's
blueprint for fascists for fascist State
down in [ __ ] Texas you don't think
that's what they want
pluck your head out of your [ __ ] ass
because that's exactly what they want
it's exactly what they want and they
won't stop they're not going to stop
even if we engage in our democracy and
we use our ballot as the heavy hammer on
fascism they won't quit
this next election in less than two
months in November is going to be the
most important election to our democracy
and as soon as it's over
as soon as it's certified the next one
will be the most important to our
democracy
it's going to take a long time to get
these [ __ ] Nazis to crawl back
underneath their [ __ ] rocks a long
time they're emboldened
Jesus Christ
so much so they're committing so much
crime they're having their phones seized
in the Hardy's drive-through
oh my [ __ ] god
whoo
what a what a news day
what a news day there's also a video out
of a clown that went into a that went
into a Dairy Queen what's the [ __ ]
fast food thing today with these with
these Trump bumpers
what is this Mike Lindell gets his
[ __ ] phone seized in Hardee's
drive-through and then a clown a trump
clown walks into a Dairy Queen
I think in Pennsylvania with a gun
and he says he's gonna kill Democrats
and liberals
and he's gonna make Donald Trump
president King of the United States
oh man this guy has been on Facebook way
too much whoosh
he was wearing a [ __ ] clown wig and I
guess a flak jacket or some [ __ ] I don't
know sounds like a gravy seal Bozo or
something
oh my God you must be a proud boy or an
oath keeper
I would imagine
but he went to the wrong restaurant you
don't make Donald Trump president King
of the United States in a Dairy Queen
everybody knows you go to Burger King
that's where you Crown the King baby
that's where the crowns are at I'm just
saying I'm just saying
oh my God this is real life folks this
is real [ __ ] life this is not made up
[ __ ] I couldn't write this [ __ ]
just couldn't do it
whew
and more news they're still toting the
queen around uh England and people here
in the United States are still paying
attention to that [ __ ] what in the [ __ ]
she's dead I don't you know a lot of
people are gonna think I'm insensitive
here but holy [ __ ]
do her a favor and put her in the
goddamn ground already [ __ ] me it's
enough of this [ __ ] and the American
Media paying attention to that nonsense
over there [ __ ] that [ __ ] enough of this
Monarch stuff I was okay with giving her
great respect the first couple [ __ ]
days
but the American Media and I really
don't give a [ __ ] about her really I
could care [ __ ] less she's a goddamn
Queen who gives a rat's ass we got a lot
better [ __ ] to worry about than when
this Queen's gonna be put in in for her
final dirt nap
there'll be plenty of time to go pay
your respects I'm sure they'll have a
[ __ ] some kind of [ __ ] huge
Cathedral that she'll be in but you'll
go be able to sit and cry about how she
died when she was 96. the longest
serving Monarch get the [ __ ] out of here
ceremonial [ __ ] autocracy [ __ ]
it's enough of that nonsense I'm tired
of the American Media [ __ ] covering
this [ __ ] are you I'm sick of this we
got we got an election here less than
two [ __ ] months that is determinant
of rather we have a democracy or not and
they're covering the queen
carrying her body around England who
gives a rat's ass let them people in
England tote around and go to the and
look at her [ __ ] casket
why in the hell is the American Media
concerned about a a monarch in a box
when we got democracy to save here not
autocracy because that's the [ __ ]
that's the choice you have is you can
have the Trump monarchy autocracy that's
what they all want that's what these
Nazis want
or you can have democracy you can have
freedom you can have Liberty you can
have rights
you can choose that's that's kind of
your choice here that's kind of your
choice here which leads me to my special
guest of today this is very important we
have some special guests our first guest
is Jeff temmer
senior advisor to the Lincoln project
he's a political strategist
he's gonna come talk to us about what's
going on in Michigan
we watched uh a report I believe it was
last week
uh CNN did this report believe it or not
about
a Michigan County Republican chairperson
who is holding Zoom meetings to try to
train people how to overturn elections
I'm not [ __ ] you
and they're using all kinds of of these
insurrectionists
to train these people
that's what that's what the [ __ ] they're
doing so when you got Jeff on to come
talk to us about that about how we can
stay vigilant because we have to we have
to engage because these people are going
to engage rather we do or not
and they're going to gauge to destroy
democracy not
not to save it they want to destroy
democracy
so we're gonna have Jeff on we also have
Trump's former attorney
Michael Cohen on at the bottom of the
second hour
we're gonna have Michael Cohen on he's
going to talk about the golf course trip
to DC I had questions for Michael I was
like uh maybe Michael knows
what Trump does on golf courses in these
secret meetings
and I watched a video that he did about
secret meetings with attorneys on golf
courses
I would imagine that this guy is scared
a shitload of people are wearing wires
right
are that are that rooms are bugged and
[ __ ] he's probably [ __ ] paranoid as
[ __ ] by now I mean just absolutely
paranoid
so I don't know if if this was kind of
like a good Fellas golf golf session
type thing
but we're gonna ask Michael Cohen his
opinion on that we're also going to talk
about the Berman book
the former sdny uh prosecuting attorney
that's that's going around selling a
book saying that he was pushed out of
the sdny by Barr and Trump sounds like
more corruption sounds like more
investigations he just [ __ ] Grace
Just pile it on
just piling on the Cheeto dust mobster
oh so we're gonna talk to Jeff temmer
and Michael Cohen today Jeff Timmer is
going to join us at the bottom of this
hour Michael Cohen will join us at the
bottom of next hour so we'll do what
we'll do is we'll do a quick [ __ ] list
Roundup we got a quick one today because
I got some video to show you we want to
show you the Lindsey Graham video
um I also I also want to show you some
of this Mike Lindell stuff you just I
mean this this is just this guy's been
going on and on and on about [ __ ]
election fraud and all kinds of [ __ ]
he's destroyed his [ __ ] reputation if
he even had one
he [ __ ] has probably destroyed his
[ __ ] business he has to he has to
sell slippers
on Fox News and Newsmax I'm not [ __ ]
you he's on Fox News and Newsmax on
their commercial selling slippers you
know the ones that Rudy Giuliani Pence
to I mean Rudy giant he's broke so he's
got to get a little bit of money pimping
slippers
so um we're going to show you some of
the Mike Glendale video I also if we got
time which we're going to be short on it
but if we got time I want to show you
the uh
every every time Mike Lindell
Trends on Twitter uh someone posts this
uh I think Adam barcaminko always posts
this video where Mike Lindell is sitting
in like it seems like a courtyard of a a
hotel or something I don't know it's
like a public [ __ ] place there's
people walking around and [ __ ] and Mike
Lindell is sitting in his underwear
on live TV
and then a guy approaches him and [ __ ]
with him you know on live TV but Mike
Lindell is sitting in his underwear in a
courtyard
it's really [ __ ] weird but you know
you shouldn't expect anything more or
less from the CEO of my pillow
the my pillow Nazi Mike Lindell is
either Mike pellar is either my slipper
Nazi now I don't know he sells sheets
and slippers
on Fox News I think the uh the pillow
Market is dried up for him I don't know
I have no idea really honestly I don't
know much about the
the uh the pillow Market but
he's in the slipper market now he's in
the sheets oh man the greatest sheets
ever too the [ __ ] out of here with that
sheet
what do you think he was ordering at
Hardee's what do you think
what do you think he was or what do you
think Mike Lindell orders and Artie's
does he order like a double cheese with
a side of treason or something I don't
know
what do you think
oh [ __ ] this morning he released a video
too on Twitter saying that he was gonna
try to get his phone back
he's trying to get his phone back this
guy is a [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy is a
[ __ ] but in better news
yesterday Joe Biden was at the white
house uh our friend of the show JoJo
from jurors shout out to Jojo uh it
looks like she was in Newsweek believe
it or not
JoJo was in Newsweek that Joe Biden had
a event at the white house yesterday and
JoJo from jurors our friend of the show
went and
and she uh
she she took a picture with the
president of the United States Joe Biden
and someone asked her I believe in the
thread how did he smell and Joe gave one
of her prolific answers
as she normally does in the replies and
uh a lot of people took
they took it the wrong way they just
didn't like that she with how she
described it she described it as uh he
smelt like a hot cup of cocoa
and they didn't like that they didn't
like that so Newsweek wrote a story I'm
not [ __ ] you this is what the
American Media is focused on
this is what they're focused on it is
crazy I actually I'm hoping that I can
bring Joe on uh maybe in the next few
days and talk to her about this weird
thing where she went to the White House
normal invited to the White House went
to the White House when you go to the
White House sometimes you take a picture
with I don't know the president of the
United States who lives and works at the
White House
and then she describes her experience
and it ends up in Newsweek
because she said hot cup of cocoa this
is really [ __ ] weird this is what the
American Media is focused on whoosh
whoosh
we got democracy to save you want to
know why we're in such a sh a shitty
position here of these fascists knocking
on her front door one of the reasons why
is the Free Press doesn't seem furry
anymore it seems bought and paid for
Jesus [ __ ] Christ
I don't mind Newsweek doing a story on
JoJo from jurors but there's a hell of a
lot better angles
of JoJo from jurors about how she's
doing she's doing the service
of resistors on Twitter
she's one of the leaders on Twitter for
resistors
I believe
and and the story is she tweeted
something about Joe Biden smelled like a
or it smelt or felt like a hot cup of I
don't know maybe we'll get to that tweet
too
Jesus Christ what she's trying to say
what she's trying to say is it's not a
dumpster fire at the White House that's
what she's trying to say okay Newsweek
okay critics
and I I read part of the news we think
they weren't too tough on her but Jesus
Christ
this is this is where we're at this is
where we're at when we actually should
be focused on Lindsey Graham and the
Republican Party the Monica Republicans
wanting to take away your rights and
your freedoms on a federal level and not
just a federal level but a state level
so what you have to do to head this off
what you have to do to make sure to make
sure
that they do not take your rights and
your freedoms away from you because
that's what they want to do
and they're telling you out loud they're
saying it in front of microphones and
cameras
to make sure you know hey elect us we
will take your rights away literally
that's what they're saying
Lindsey Graham said if you put
Republicans in charge of the house and
the Senate we will make sure to take
your rights away from you
we are planning on it we got a bill
already written to take your [ __ ]
rights away from you
your freedom we want to take your
freedom away vote for us literally is
what they're saying they're handing us
this election folks they're handing it
to us
all we have to do is get out there and
[ __ ] pound the Earth with this
messaging pound it
and leave no stone unturned and don't
give a [ __ ] if we Scorch the Earth with
it [ __ ] them we have to politicize every
single issue every one of them
and this one
this one has got people pissed off it's
got the electorate pissed off and
there's no better opportunity
than to make sure we save our democracy
with this little nugget that the
Republicans have given us because
they've shown their cards they've shown
their cards that they're anti-American
they're anti-freedom they're anti-woman
they're anti-privacy and and they just
[ __ ] hate that other people who don't
aren't them and don't look like them
have [ __ ] rights and Liberty
they're saying it out loud
Now's the Time for you to act you can do
this
make sure to check your [ __ ]
registration
double check it don't just assume you
can vote I don't care what [ __ ] State
you're in
I don't give a [ __ ]
we not only do we have to make sure we
secure the Senate
and we make sure
that we have Democrats in the majority
of the house
but we have to pile mountains
and mountains of votes on these
[ __ ]
we have to show not just ourselves but
the entire world that no this [ __ ]
white Christian nationalist America
first fascist let's go Brandon Nazi
party
is not us
it's a slim percentage Yeah there's a
lot of these [ __ ] Knuckleheads out
there numbers wise but it's a slim
percentage they do not represent us
thank you
we want democracy we want Equity we want
equality we want rights Liberty and
freedom and we must engage and we must
fight for it
it is most important I don't again I
don't care if you're in a blue state in
a blue County a blue City you pile these
[ __ ] in votes
it is a statement we have to make
we cannot just win
we have to destroy
the America first fascist party
the Maga Republicans we have to burn
their house down
and the way we do that is not play these
stupid little games where oh we can't
say this we can't bull [ __ ] politicize
every single issue
every one of them
and the main one is what Lindsey Graham
said in front of a microphone yesterday
is what everyone has been telling
everyone in this country these Maga
Republicans the tail is wagging the dog
and the bigots the racist the anti the
anti-women crowd
they have taken over the Maga
Republicans and they want to take your
freedoms away from you
so listen to them when they tell you who
they are when Lindsey Graham who again
was supposed to be the moderate and
worked across the aisle and work with
Democrats to get compromised and do good
government is standing in front of a
microphone saying vote for Republicans
we're going to take away your freedom
that's their messaging we got them
they're on their heels
all we have to do is lean in just lean
into democracy
and engage in the ballot
that's all we have to do
that's all you have to do
so stay steady
no
the prize
and don't get too distracted by clowns
walking in
into a Dairy Queen claiming they're
gonna make Donald Trump the president
King Jesus [ __ ] Christ don't go
anywhere we're going to be right back
with Jeff temmer everyone stick around
we'll be right back right after this
break
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product part in blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
Boy we got a big show for you today
there's a lot of news
but the biggest news there is
we are so damn close to these midterms
we are approaching very close I have my
co-host Dave Sanchez and our guests Jeff
Timmer
advisor to the Lincoln project Jeff how
are you I am great Tony it's great to be
here it's great to see you and Gabe
hey hi what's up you know this is this
is crazy the reason and and I asked last
week after we watched um CNN had a a
little uh report that they did and you
actually appeared in it for a few
seconds a few minutes I think
um you were talking to them about
Michigan because you know a thing or two
about Michigan politics and really the
Republicans in Michigan you used to be a
republican head of something in Michigan
right so my my thought was is I wanted
to have you on to really explain to
people what they're trying to do because
it was a little because they were
talking about you know or they're using
Zoom meetings to train them as spies and
things of this nature but it really was
unclear uh in their reporting I thought
CNN did a good job but they really
didn't hit the target so I wanted to
have you on to create a piece of content
to hit the target here right in the on
the bullseye of what these people are
trying to do well let's do that then
let's let's show CNN how it's done
um what what uh what the Michigan
Republicans are doing is they are
training uh volunteers they're
Grassroots supporters these Mega tinfoil
uh horse-paced eating Kooks to go out
and become official election inspectors
and what though when you go into vote
you go into your Precinct and there's
all the people sitting at the table to
check you in
um and uh in Most states those those
people are volunteers or they're paid
some small stipend but they're supposed
to represent a bipartisan mix uh if if
uh equal number of Republicans and
Democrats apply that's what they're
supposed to do is to make sure that
these elections are unfairly to have a
bipartisan uh group of of people running
the election and so what the Michigan
Republican party is trying to do is to
get these people their their their
trained zealots into these official
election spots in these trainings that
they're doing trying to stay out of the
public eye but CNN exposed them these
trainings are telling them their their
how to gum up how to be how to throw a
wrench in the gears of democracy and
that's what it's all about is is they
want to gum up the works on Election Day
make it more difficult for people to
vote in uh key Democratic areas they
want to cast aspersions on the veracity
of the election on the uh undermine the
faith and the results so that democracy
is further undermined and they can make
their move to try to win the election
so what you're saying it sounds like
is that and me and Gabe kind of surmised
this the other day is that the
Republicans are trying to plan on doing
what they accused Democrats of doing in
2020 do I have that right am I am I all
the mark there or well you know I guess
it depends on whether you're seen or if
you're a republican the Republicans
think they're doing this to save
democracy right they view themselves as
the they're laying down on the tracks
between cannibal socialists and uh you
know uh the Constitution uh but what
they're doing is they're they're
radicalizing these people in like this
Isis Manner and they're they're using
online training to recruit find and and
uh radicalize these people convince them
that there's this uh uh nefarious acts
going on and they're the only ones who
can you know strap the the the the bomb
to their chest and go in and save save
democracy and I know that sounds a
little hyperbolic but that's what these
guys are doing they're blowing up our
faith and elections when before 2020
this sounds pretty simple uh before 2020
everybody agreed Republicans Democrats
that on Election Day you vote you count
the votes somebody wins somebody loses
the loser licks their wounds and you go
on to fight the next election no one
ever just said we're not gonna We're Not
Gonna accept the results we're just
going to refuse to leave we're going to
refuse to abide by the results it
doesn't matter who actually got the
right votes we're going to kick and
scream and make a lot of noise and you
know try to use the courts try to use
subterfuse try to throw these Hail Mary
passes to uh insert our candidates into
these positions whether or not they get
the most votes and if we have to rely on
worrying about who and how the votes are
being counted uh in in getting our
getting people in in positions that will
be fair democracy is over if we can't
have that shared faith that the winners
Is Win
we're done after 246 years
well I think it's also uh it's the more
and more I think about you know
everyone's attempt on the Republican
side to uh to fight election fraud by
committing you know or actually
committee I don't put quotes they're
actually committing election fraud it
reminds me almost like it's the plot of
National Treasure like Nick Cage has to
steal the Constitution to avoid the bad
guy from stealing the Constitution to
protect it but that's not the case here
right they're not they're actually
committing the thing that they're
projecting on to Democrats or the left
and I think it's also your the timing of
you being on the show I think is is
incredible because just yesterday as
Tony was taught I was talking about in
the beginning half of the show is Mike
Lindell gets his phone seized at the
drive-through of a Hardee's but the
reason now while that is hilarious
because you could not write a better
scenario
if it wasn't right exactly right
um but the thing that is so
uh so perfect about the timing is that
what is being discussed right now about
election fraud and these people
attempting to to uh to commit election
fraud to save the election is the
connection between Michael and Dell and
Tina Peters right and in what she I mean
she's facing 10 criminal charges seven
of which are felonies and she just
continues to blab around about how uh
she's innocent and she's fighting this
and fighting that but she is another
person who did this exact same thing
went to one of these meetings learned
how to go in stolen I.T consultant's ID
badge like this is the extent I mean
they'll probably go even further you
know in the future as well well they
have and in Michigan uh they there are
the the guy that the Republicans
nominated to run for the office of
Attorney General is one of nine people
who are facing indictment for election
fraud after the 2020 election uh
including there's a state representative
a sitting Republican state
representative and the guy running for
attorney general the Attorney General's
office uh kind of ironically was the one
investigating this crime and then it's
revealed that the the guy running
against the Attorney General
is likely a felon uh so the they had to
refer they've created a special
prosecutor now to decide whether or not
to indict these people but they went
around doing exactly that same thing
they they purported to be officials
conducting a state investigation uh They
seized election equipment from local
clerks all around the state and then
they dismantled these uh damaged these
very expensive sophisticated
computerized pieces of equipment and
returned them inoperable to all these
these places and this is apparently like
a [ __ ] ton of felonies that they
committed in the process impersonating
uh law enforcement all these different
things uh not to mention the the actual
tampering with the the the uh official
election equipment which is a felony
itself and so this is it's something
they have been doing there are so many
Michigan Republicans high level profile
Michigan Republicans who are under
criminal investigation or actual
indictments the list it's easier to list
those who aren't under criminal
investigation it's insane there are
literally dozens Speaker of the House
the Senate Majority Leader the guy
running for attorney general the
co-chair of the party the National
Committee woman who serves on the RNC
there's just dozens of these people who
are under criminal investigation it's
it's insane sounds like it sounds like a
plot from New Jersey
um or something like that or a plot from
Pennsylvania where a trump clown walks
into a Dairy Queen
um going to kill liberals and Democrats
and he's going to Crown Donald Trump
president King of the United States I'm
not making that [ __ ] up either that is
that is the craziest part right now is
that it sounds like those the criminal
Republicans are using what power they
think they have which um I think Justice
departments whether it be federal or
state local are going to you know hamper
that down but we watched a bunch of a
video of a bunch of clowns walking into
Coffee County Georgia doing the same
exact kind of [ __ ] and this was this was
the day after after the Insurrection
when they knew the Insurrection wasn't
going to work they were they were going
and tampering with machines now they
weren't actually wearing clown wigs like
the guy at the Dairy Queen but they
wanted to do the same thing which was
Crown Trump president King of the United
States
we can't make this [ __ ] up but really
the thing that the thing I think that is
um missing here is that this is so
important that we pay attention to
what's happening locally because that's
actually where our elections happen is
on a local level that's why this
nonsense about like Lindsey Graham and
other stoking riots and [ __ ] like that
if Trump's indicted like where are they
gonna go are they going to go to each
County election office and do an
Insurrection there or something I mean
this doesn't make sense 2020 was uh was
a different election and January 6 was a
was a different type of certification
than what we're going to have in these
midterms but what we really need to
worry about is what you're saying is not
just in Michigan because it sounds like
there's a huge disease in Michigan but
all these states like Kerry Lake and
Blake Masters
um Herschel Walker which is batshit
crazy uh JD Vance and and all these
Secretary of States and these governors
in these races gaining power or Over
States which that's where the power of
those of those local elections are yeah
they've been since since the they lost
the 2020 election they've been paying
great attention to very minute details
in the election process all across the
country they're installing people like
in these Precinct locations like we've
been talking about they're installing
election deniers in these certification
boards uh across the country people who
at the county level or Precinct level
and state level are vowing ahead of time
they're saying I would not have
certified the 2020 results I will not
certify the 2022 or 2024 results because
they want to create this chaos they want
to create this vacuum where they think
they're you know clown uh wig Mega King
can come in and and be anointed than a
king in the the vacuum that they create
once the gears grind to a halt in the
the uh the logistics of Elections and
but
one they're [ __ ] crazy I mean we we
know that but they're diligent they
don't stop they don't they don't realize
they're crazy crazy doesn't sleep they
do this 24 7. they're they're paying
attention to this every day they've got
thousands of people spread across the
country that are paying attention to
this to getting their uh people elected
to school boards and this Deluge of of
new we hear this stuff every day it's
this constant drip of of news like this
but it's like the Frog boiling in the
water we don't realize how hot the water
is getting and how democracy is about to
that boiling temperature until it's too
late there's it's it's it's so hard to
tell everybody be alarmed all the time
but we need to be alarmed all the
goddamn time
right because they're not gonna stop me
and Gabe talk about it all the time here
on the show they just they're Relentless
and now what they want is not something
that they're willing to give up and it's
going to take a long time to get some of
these
um folks that support them the crawl
back underneath their their rocks as it
as it were
um but back to the training sessions on
Zoom when you were part of the
Republican party I mean Republicans met
to strategize elections and to make sure
that they were secure they were Fair
Democrats do the same thing there's a
lot of State parties that have their
hotlines for voter fraud and stuff of
that nature to make sure that our
elections are fair because we do need to
be diligent about that um they've kind
of taken over that um you know that
wording and projected it and done the
whole National Treasure thing where they
think they're saving election but
they're they're stealing it
um but explain the difference between
when you were involved in the Michigan
Republican Party starting when you guys
were really trying to do democracy a
service and trying to make sure that
they were fair and then the difference
now and what they're saying about spying
I mean they're using the word
not Espionage but close to it as their
manga King their clown Maga King is
committing Espionage they want to commit
Espionage on our elections but explain
exactly
what they're they're training these
people to do what's their aim here well
both parties historically have had their
their foot soldiers they're loyalists
their their Precinct delegates whoever
uh you know their activists are on
Election Day doing things that help get
out their vote make sure that uh their
people are showing up to vote monitoring
the lists of people on Election Day
who've actually shown up to vote so they
know who hasn't shown up and they need
to start calling them knocking on their
doors that's been kind of the primary
function of of Election Day activities
there's also been an effort everybody
transparency and sunlight help the
election process right we it's open to
the public anybody can go in and watch
the the election in the precinct being
conducted they can go in and watch the
votes uh being processed and counted
provided they don't disrupt and and uh
get in the way of that being done uh in
in that's what both parties have
historically done is deputize people to
be those eyes and ears watch for
anything uh out of sorts and and there's
you
there's seldom uh anything really out of
sorts what there are is usually people
who are aren't trained very well
thinking there's something out of sorts
or there's a human error involved you
know the the little old ladies running
the election make some mistake along the
way that's that's fixed by the local
clerk but it's kind of reported up the
food chain and it makes everybody wiggle
around and get agitated for a couple
minutes but that's that's been the
historic uh extent of of how this is
done but what they're telling these
people to do like they caught they
caught them on the CNN report uh they
they gained access to one of their their
Zoom sessions uh that were where they
were training these people and they're
telling them
things that are they're saying that look
it's illegal for you to take your phone
in but do it anyway uh it's illegal for
you to record and videotape this but do
it anyway uh they're they're telling
them they're instructing them to break
the law to commit misdemeanors in this
case uh in in that's their plan ahead of
time and they're going into this with
the intent to undermine the law and
break the law to to reach and achieve
their ends which is creating this smoke
screen that there's something going on
that isn't
well and it sounds like to me because I
grew up on a farm and we had we had
fences and Gates right and you know
generally speaking you could just hop
over a fence or a gate I mean most
people can but we used to put a chain
around the gate and we would put a
padlock on it and we wouldn't actually
lock the padlock because it was a
padlock we didn't have a key for when I
was a kid I said why do we put that
padlock on there and not lock it my dad
would say it's to keep an honest man
honest and I think that's what you're
saying is is the system that we've set
in place in our democracy there are
there are a lot of Unwritten rules but
the unwritten rule is is that there is
oversight and those and both parties are
standing there to make sure that that no
one in the election process is swaying
the election one way or the other and
and they're very diligent each party is
very diligent about having people there
to make sure to keep it quote unquote
honest man honest as my my dad would say
with that padlock because anyone could
just jump the fence or go through the
gate or whatever it's just a lot people
know hey you're not supposed to do
things you're not supposed to do but
what you're saying
is the Michigan Republicans and I'm sure
this is happening other places around
the country are saying nope go do those
things that you're not supposed to do
and I think that's the scary part here
is that we have a situation where
there's one party in the country that is
only for democracy that the other party
is not for it and what is even scarier
is what uh Gabe alluded to earlier is
the delusion that they are for democracy
yeah yeah and and well that's there's
this this
um kind of uh normalcy bias that pundits
have that uh reporters have that we see
on the news where they're kind of
treating what's going on in these last
few years as politics though this is
just politics
but it's not this is not politics we
have one side playing by the political
rules within the confines of democracy
and we got one side that's tipped the
board over is just eating the pieces and
throwing them all around the [ __ ]
room and there's there's two different
games going on here and but it's the the
consequences are real and it can't just
be treated as well you know the the
Republicans say this the Democrats say
this you know back to you Jim there's
there's
there's something there's a
responsibility that people have people
with microphones you know like like us
here but really in the in the in the
news media the cable news media to stop
normalizing the abnormal and that's
something that we've done over these
that collectively when I say we uh have
started to look at this as well you know
there's there's there people are upset
about the elections and the process and
there's some distrust so we have to you
know we have in the state legislatures
we have to introduce these laws to
restore the faith in uh election
outcomes well that's the Republicans are
saying that all around the country
that's like you know the the arsonist
that's the [ __ ] fire and say well you
know this is great because now the fire
department has all this work to do we
need to we need to make sure that the
fire department has plenty of work
so let's go around setting fires and
that's good for democracy that's that's
their position and it's being it they're
getting away with it in a lot of cases
because people are just like I said they
get normal sane people get tired of
fighting the crazy 24 7 arguing with the
crazy debating the crazy they don't
necessarily believe that the sky is
falling even though the evidence before
our eyes says the sky is falling uh and
that's that's where the the the
complacency the the the the just kind of
hearing this day in day out on the news
it kind of goes into the back of our
mind it's not at the Forefront people
aren't as alarmed as they should be I
don't think a lot of Democrats in the
the the the the uh in the political
system and the operation of of politics
government and elections are as
concerned as they should be some are
many are but some of them aren't they're
still treating what's going on as a
political part of person difference and
they're fighting it in that political
partisan way that okay we disagree but
we're working towards you know we need
to find some kind of way to get along
well you can't get along with somebody
who's trying to who's trying to you know
effectively you know choke the life out
of out of our the American Republic
yeah so you actually bring up a good
point which is like this desensitive
like desensitizing people right the
American public we've got you know we
went through you know five years of this
you know as it led up but really the
five years concentrated within this time
of taking away people's rights you know
uh bigotry uh xenophobia hatred like
this whole platform that Trump ran on
and a lot of these Republicans you know
these mag Republicans really you know
were like great this is exactly what I
believe in and now it's on a national
stage so we're gonna Double Down
and it really is
um in many ways it can be exhausting
right to hear this type of rhetoric this
language and and know for how many years
being like well I guess nothing's gonna
happen right and now we're you know now
we're seeing everything kind of this
domino effect and or the snowball effect
of everything's piling up and we're
beginning to see actual Justice or uh or
change by removing you know like there
there is a we have a cancer or a virus
and we need to fight it right now and
that is what we're cutting out from the
from the body part
um but there and I I guess my question
for you is
knowing how desensitized we are as you
know American people and knowing that we
hear this every single day I mean Mike
Lindell even said last night in a show
he was he was talking about uh something
that you just brought up which is like
great there's a fire the fire department
should be fighting more fires right
and last night on the show he made a
whole he's like oh great there's
election fraud good right but he's part
of this group that is causing the issue
and I'm going great now they have more
work to do which is like they have other
[ __ ] to deal with they don't need to
deal with the stuff that you've created
so I guess you know what I'm curious
about is
what what can we do right like how can
outside of you know the justice
department and actual like people going
to court and Seeking Justice for this
but like what can we do as Citizens to
help fight this normalcy that the media
is creating
well
one thing is we need to be we need to
keep keep shouting from the rooftops
that there's a fire
um
you know people you know you've been
online now for a long time doing this
there are many uh like us who are out
there doing it uh uh my colleagues at
the the Lincoln project have been doing
it for a long time
um we've been saying uh for the last
year that we need to make
the fight for democracy a national issue
in this election and we're finally
starting to see that happen with Joe
Biden's speech on Democracy a couple of
weeks ago there have been polls out in
the National polls and in the states
where democracy is now the the the the
issue of democracy is now risen in the
issues in the Forefront of Voters Minds
where it's one of the top issues you've
got uh the economy and inflation you've
got abortion uh you've got democracy Now
emerge has emerged as a key issue in in
the campaign and we need to keep that
drum beat going we need to encourage
people that there sometimes it feels
like there's
like there's so damn many of these crazy
Kooks out there on the mega side doing
this stuff but they are a very they're a
very squealing loud minority and we
can't forget that there's a ton more of
us than there are of them and we need to
act like it we need to get out there and
encourage people to vote to get
registered to make sure they're donating
to campaigns five ten dollars whatever
more if you can give it they need to get
involved in local campaigns get involved
with local Democratic parties and I say
that as somebody who's not a Democrat I
know people have started to identify me
as a Democrat but I'm I was a republican
all my life I have not I don't agree
with Democrats on policy issues but
we're not having fights about marginal
tax rates right now and if we are if
you're having that fight with anybody
out there uh stop because democracy is
freaking on fire and that's where we
need to be focusing and so the only
pro-democracy party out there right now
is the Democratic party and people need
to be out there talking about how
important it is to vote for the
Democrats uh if you are a center-right
voter if you are a moderate Republican
and you're you know shaking your head at
this but you've never voted for a
Democrat before now is the time it's not
hard it doesn't make you feel bad I've
done it uh get out there and do it
because democracy is at stake whether or
not we continue to have free and fair
elections uh the 2024 election we have
to be prepared is going to be far worse
than what we saw in the 2020 election in
in after we have to start preparing
ourselves for that disruption for the uh
more crazy more chaos more violence
unfortunately but uh we need to start
having those Frank conversations with
with people uh groups that were part of
friends neighbors family uh don't stop
trying to persuade people uh who who can
get involved in vote this election this
midterm election is very very critical
arguably and I know people always love
to say this is the most important
election of our lifetime this could be
the most important off-year
off-presidential election uh in American
history if these election Kooks win in
the the especially the existential
States as I call them Pennsylvania
Michigan Wisconsin Arizona Nevada and
Georgia they're going to
put their thumb on the scale when it
after the 2024 election and we're going
to be in a crisis like we've never had
in this country before
there's something else you brought up I
think is really interesting and
obviously something that is the kind of
the pulse of of topic right now outside
of our democracy is on fire with just a
free and fair election but something you
know that we see that on the right which
is Roe v Wade and just I think it was
yesterday or the day before Lindsey
Graham goes up and says uh you know a
white man not a woman uh would never go
through this himself decides what the
rules should be on a national ban for
this so like you know what are you what
are your thoughts when it comes to when
you hear stuff like that
well
the whole premise of the Dobbs decision
was that this was a something that
should be left to the states to decide
that's what the Supreme Court what their
decision uh was was uh based around we
can certainly disagree on whether or not
they should have done that or not and
all the Republicans said well this
should be an issue that states decide
and then immediately Lindsey Graham's
out there saying no we need to have a
federal ban and he really I think is
helping
uh keep this issue this this issue is
going to be I think the the preeminent
issue driving turnout and driving
intensity in in this campaign there are
more when I say there are more of us
than there are of them it applies to
people who are pissed off about the road
decision and that even applies to people
Republicans who have considered
themselves pro-life
for whom
criminalizing putting their their
sisters their cousins their daughters
their granddaughters in prison about
abortion putting doctors and nurses in
prison over abortion that's something
that nobody has ever contemplated
seriously and now that they're forced to
confront that for the first time in 50
years a whole lot of people who have
been part of the pro-life movement on
the Republican side are suddenly like no
no no no no no no this is a bridge too
far you guys have lost your goddamn
Minds there's you're you you don't even
support exceptions uh for abortion for
rape and incest like the governor
candidate here in in Michigan where I am
who is is proudly she's gone on TV and
given an interview and talked about how
she would force a 14 year old to have
her rapist baby you know effectively tie
this girl to the chair for nine months
and give birth to a baby because she
says that it's it's a way she can heal
from the rape I mean these people are
insane it is you know it's it's too easy
to call it the hand handmaid's Tale But
That's What It Is Well you know I think
the issue of Roe goes back to the top
issue of democracy because it's not just
about abortion right because you're
you're right there's there's people who
are are out there that have considered
themselves pro-life their entire life or
their entire you know thought process
behind abortion and really it's not
about abortion itself it's about are we
willing to let to let politicians and
let the government federal state local
tell us what we can and cannot do with
our bodies in the privacy of a doctor's
office about medical procedures I think
that really goes to the heart of it and
the other thing too Jeff before we go is
I think what they've really done with
this road thing not just piss people off
about freedom but they have pissed women
off I mean they have pissed them off it
seems like in almost all states the
registration is up and it's up among a
very specific demographic which is
people who are at the tail end of these
Republicans taking away someone's
Freedom
um before we go tell us one tell us if
you think if I'm a spot on about that
women being pissed here I live in a I
live in a house with four women over the
age of 20. uh and I can attest that you
are spot on they are pissed they are mad
their friends are mad they talk about it
and it's not just the women it is it is
uh it's Dad's it's Brothers It's people
who who are saying they're they're
looking in in for the first time in
their lives you know because it's been
50 years of of Roe being in place until
it isn't 50 years of not having to
seriously contemplate the alternative
the alternative people are finding out
is uh people dying potentially in
emergency rooms because doctors aren't
sure whether or not they can perform
procedures that are necessary to save or
protect the health of a mother we're
seeing people facing criminal felony
charges in possible prison over abortion
and people are like what the hell's
happened we can't allow this to happen
we're going to turn out and vote
well before we go thanks thanks for
joining us do you have a Shameless plug
you'd like to give Jeff well follow me
on Twitter I'm at Jeff Timmer uh I I
don't swear as much as Tony but I come
close oh well [ __ ] well come back and
you can swear you can swear as much as
you want anytime you want right here but
yeah always the f word is always welcome
here on our show the Tony Michaels
podcast Jeff thanks a lot for joining us
I really appreciate it do not be shy
everyone stick around we'll be back with
the shitless Roundup we're gonna surf
the Tweety tweets and 20 trendy Trends
before we bring on Michael Cohen at the
bottom of the next hour thanks Jeff
we'll talk to you soon my friend
everyone stick around we'll be right
back right after this break
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam jams skull
near run out Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again years
bomb
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show we're gonna do
a quick round of shitless Roundup we
want to serve the sweet Journey Trends
we got plenty of Mike Lindell my fellow
Nazi videos to show you we also have a
video about this clown in Pennsylvania
who wants to Crown Donald Trump the
president King of the United States
whatever the [ __ ] that is oh my God the
fast food the fast food content is is
heavy this morning Gabe I am waiting I
am waiting for a comment from any of
these fast food restaurants because
right I mean I don't know people know
this but on social media at least like
in 2018 2019 all of these uh companies
these Brands developed these like uh
very existential or or rather uh
uh uh almost like an alter ego right
yeah they've got these personas now
where they talk as if they're real
things right Arby's is great at it yeah
yeah and there's you know Wendy's uh
Wendy's is good there's a bunch of
frozen food items that I've seen before
the brands they talk to each other
Burger King's another one right but I am
very curious to see if somewhere like a
Wendy's or uh and RVs or you know a
Hardee's wants to chime in and say you
know make some joke because I would
definitely make a joke about maybe
there's a you know if you use this
discount code or whatever you get an
item 50 off or 50 off uh your cell phone
being seized I don't know let's do this
because we don't got much time because
Michael Cohen's coming on at the bottom
of this hour hell yeah less than 30
minutes we're gonna have Michael Cohen
on we're gonna ask him Gabe about the DC
trip that Trump made on the golf course
what the hell he was out there talking
about it Michael knows anything about it
that's right if he knows is anything
about Trump having secret meetings he's
probably the guy to talk to you so we're
going to ask we're also going to ask him
about the Berman book that Berman's
going around talking about how Donald
Trump and Bill Barr are corrupt and they
try to sneak him out of the sdny oh who
would have thunk it would have thinking
so let's do this let's surf the Tweety
tweets and the journey Trends start the
countdown
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tweets and trendy Trends you have to
know the news and we're gonna keep you
informed and today there's a heavy fast
food theme Here is uh Adam Parker minko
he said who made this
um this uh you were talking about
someone making a joke this is apparently
a hearty sign that says now serving my
pillow Guide to the FBI
so wherever the hell this hearty is
Hardee's is they have a [ __ ] sense of
humor yeah and for the West Coast people
a Hardee's is known as a Carl's Jr yes
it's very confusing it's very confusing
you know it's a it was a merger they
brought it together they have very
different demographics but the menu
items are almost identical right and the
star is the same too the star is the
same they're starting you know one is I
think called a thick burger and the
other one's like a charred broiled
burger or something like that I see
here's another piece of news that I
think everyone's not paying attention to
that I want to show you uh Kyle Stewart
has it here CIA director William Burns
is in the capital this evening he was
being escorted by house Intel ranking
member Turner speaker Pelosi Intel chair
Schiff and leader McCarthy all went to
the same location in the capital here is
the um here's the picture of them
walking the CIA when the CIA director
goes and meets with the speaker of the
house
um the Intel chair uh Adam Schiff the
end the the minority leader McCarthy
something's going on something's going
on I'm just saying I don't I actually
don't know what it is and I I actually
don't know of any idea uh I think that's
kind of the point with the CIA director
being in the capital is we wouldn't know
that kind of [ __ ] um but obviously
there's something going on right it is a
secret you know what else that's how
they work you know what else is a secret
well it's not really a secret
um Stewart Rhodes is going to trial oh
but you know what's funny about this is
this [ __ ] bonehead uh Kyle has it
here he says the judge tells Rhodes
lawyer the motion for a special Master
is nonsense
Stuart Rhodes is now trying to request
request a special master so they're
literally like watching Trump do this
[ __ ] and like oh well we'll try that
that works if Trump can do it we can do
it and it just shows it just shows that
the judge Cannon is a [ __ ] bonehead
and the other thing that it tells me is
that this is this is just ridiculous
that we're even playing this game with
Trump be because the judge won't even
play the game with someone who was who
is intending to commit violence I mean
it's it is very much you know I'm glad
there are other people who practice law
and in Law and Order and actually look
at this and say this is the dumbest
[ __ ] thing I've ever heard of uh you
would not or nor should you be allowed
to have this thing based on the crimes
that you committed it's clearly out
there and every time you try to
challenge it the doj continues to reveal
more information which is what I think
what happened yesterday didn't they
reveal more info uh more details
unsealed well so the doj is requesting
for the security footage at Mar-A-Lago
to be unsealed right away which is a
huge deal if that gets released they're
really boxing TR well bot Trump is
boxing himself yeah but I mean it's it's
what he typically does I mean look he
would not have this problem if you just
shut the [ __ ] up yeah you can't shut the
[ __ ] up though because here's his
statement on Mike Lindell the guy the
dude is commenting on the Mike Lindell
Hardy's thing election for Rod were
looks like Lindell is going to be
indicted and maybe this Tina Peters case
I said dude thinks Mike Lindell was
raided literally he said rated at
Hardy's drive-through this is this is
the statement he said breaking news Mike
Lindell and I don't know why putting
quotes the pillow also the right pillow
but he's the my pillow the quotes he
loves the quotes I don't understand what
the [ __ ] that means he said he was
raided by the FBI he wasn't raided by
the FBI generally when you're rated it's
like at an office a house like a
structure that you occupy not not not
your [ __ ] Happy Meal box so I guess I
don't know what it's called at parties
so I I watched the interview that Mike
Lindell did on the Lindell report which
is hosted on Lindell TV so it's a great
moment of historical kind of uh uh
a moment that was just kind of captured
here but what's happening is this guy
goes and says I was he says Not only was
the FB oh they were nice guys they're
actually pretty nice he says that so you
know going against what Trump already
says is one he wasn't right like what
are they gonna write the airspace he was
standing in he's literally standing in
the drive through talking to the FBI and
he was like and Trump goes oh he was
rated are you [ __ ] serious right now
how could you raid the open space that
is around you you can't he gave the
phone willingly over to the FBI because
his attorney that I spoke to on the
phone before he handed it said yeah give
them the phone now I'm gonna go to some
video of Mike Lindell explaining the
situation but this is the best piece of
Mike Lindell content ever posted on the
internet this is you can see Mike
Lindell the pillow guy sitting there in
front of his two phones he has two
phones in this picture by the way which
by the way in the video he says he only
has one phone he runs all five five
businesses he doesn't have a computer
which I find that to be complete
[ __ ] based on the fact that he had
these interviews last night he had a
phone or an angle from this side and
then he was giving the the interview
from directly in front of him so I'm
having a hard time thinking that he has
only one phone right right well here he
is recording something or something but
this is a great piece of content let's
watch the first bit of this
system
you were two patriots
live on TV okay yeah now he watches this
guy backs up as he's live on TV this is
this this video encapsulates
Mike Lindell and his entire his entire
personality wants this starts call your
name don't let them call you an
ethically dubious pillow Pusher now look
here Mike Lindell I'm gonna pause it
here is in his underwear now this is
this is not like in some kind of private
room or something this seems to be in a
courtyard of a hotel somewhere somebody
so I shared this video yesterday and
somebody commented and I don't know if
this is true but they said this was at a
Courtyard at some Hotel in San Diego and
they're like oh yeah I've been there
before I've stayed in one were they
there in their underwear like in the
courtyard
like a normal thing it's like an
underwear I think that's a normal thing
in San Diego that I know I don't know if
there's like an underwear Courtyard like
they encourage people to just be in
their underwear because
jacket in his underwear doing a TV
interview and again I want to point out
he's got two phones here not just one
he's got two so he either stole
someone's phone or he actually hands to
phones but let's go to the uh the
footage where uh let's see I think yeah
should we play the one that you posted
is that the one you want to play sure
yeah yeah I mean him yeah we can go with
that one uh so let's go with this one uh
because there's I mean there's just he
can't stop talking about this I I
watched this whole thing last night and
I found some very interesting stuff but
this is how he starts the story of how
the raid or the you know him the seizure
of his phone started
oh my Okay let's listen and we go
through party's drive through
we pull around the back and we're just
about going through we pulled through
the drive through to take the order we
pull up and she says pull ahead you know
because they had to make the order card
it wasn't done we pull ahead
and a car comes perpendicular and Parks
like a little ways in front of us and I
and I've been around the block and I
said to my buddy I said
um that's either a bad guy or it's it's
FBI I I said that straight up I said
that straight up I said that don't guys
I he's been around the block he said it
straight up
I I can't so he literally knows that the
FBI has been watching him because he
yeah his because he's admitting that his
first thought is oh [ __ ] I'm in big
trouble right like it's either a bad guy
he's coming he was coming back from
hunting by the way he was like hunting
ducks or something he was mentioned in
the interview and they're like they
could have picked me up before that but
they decided to wait until I went
through the drive the Hardee's drive
through which I'm like you know I mean I
mean when you're in the drive-through it
makes sense really if you're following
someone and they go through the
drive-through they're like hey they're
gonna have to stop at the window to grab
their food so they're gonna be
distracted and it's gonna be easy to you
know really Corner them and really
because you can't get out of your car
you're right against the [ __ ] window
right and the fact that he was hunting
had a gun on him probably they were like
look we we shouldn't try to we don't
want to raise the stakes and heighten
the tension pull him over and [ __ ] yeah
yeah like if you've got weapon is on you
or you're armed at the moment when
you're [ __ ] shooting ducks
maybe we should just wait until you're
more relaxed at a hearty drive through
you're ready you're ready for that
burger in the shake I don't know what do
you think what do you think Mike Lindell
orders said Hardy's I'm not I'm not a
hearties I don't even know what is at a
hearties I mean I mean I don't know
sandwiches again I don't I I don't go to
Hardee's that often I'm not a Hardee's
fan well I haven't been to a Hardee's in
a long time and let alone a uh Carl's Jr
out here in California okay I get you I
got you well let's here's another video
this was played on Fox News this is the
other angle
he's live streaming recording here
here's the context board he's doing a
video a live stream on Facebook
simultaneously while he's doing the
interview on the Lindell report that is
on Lindell TV from franksbeach.com so he
does have another stream the [ __ ]
interview that I don't I don't know man
I don't know this [ __ ] guy okay let's
let's listen here
says show me your bag
so they saw one bad and I said how about
yours you know can I trust anybody like
you know there's bad people well they do
that they say what do you want and uh he
said we need to talk to you so I pull
over
and uh
oh Lord and uh um
we have more um more news in fast food
and I I'd love to stay on Mike Lindell
for I don't know hours yeah but there's
endless amounts of content and I I will
have I'm working on a what was that to
hopefully come out later today that is
on exactly why Mike Lindell was uh what
had his phone seized from him
well I don't know if the guy the clown
at the Dairy Queen in in Pennsylvania
had a phone on him but he definitely had
a gun on him and he was wearing a trump
wig I mean a clown wig but listen to
this report now when I first watched
this video I'm like what the hell is
this about it it takes a huge Maga right
turn
um at one point in this local news
report watch this before and it's
fortunate no one was hurt Belmont Police
say this all started as a 9-1-1 call for
an erratic driver along State Route 66.
police say the caller reported seeing a
man wearing a safety vest and rainbow
clown wig get out of his vehicle with a
gun in his hand before walking into this
Dairy Queen Delmont police say an
officer was nearby and responded
immediately and met the man as he was
coming out of the store taking him into
custody without incident police say the
man had a loaded 40 caliber handgun in
his pocket Jesus search also found two
more loaded handguns in his vehicle when
police asked him about the weapons
police tell us the man said he was quote
undercover and working to restore Trump
as president Trump
are you [ __ ] serious he was armed to
kill Democrats and liberals and protect
himself from drug traffickers the owner
of the Dairy Queen declined to comment
on the incident to Delmont police chief
tells us he believes his officer
prevented a possible mass casualty type
situation police did file charges but
they have not identified
this guy is he thinks he's undercover so
he's wearing a clown and I I misspoke I
said a flight ticket early but I did
right exactly he's camouflage
um he's got a clown wig on but he's got
a safety vest so I'm assuming that maybe
it's an orange or neon vest I thought
they meant Flak Jacket earlier when I
watched it because I was so focused on
the president King what the hell is that
President well that's the same type of
stuff you hear the time all the they
want to restore the Maga King Donald
Trump Jr guy who is fascinated whether
through its nepotism desire to be
rewarded through nepotism or there's
some other weird [ __ ] uh kink that
he's into but Don Jr always sends out
texts and emails that's like hey restore
the Maga King donate to the Maga King my
dad is the Maga King here's a photo of
my dad is the Maga King it's [ __ ]
weird man there's a weird kind of
obsession just because he's looking for
his daddy's little love you know but
this isn't the same same just it's the
same language too kill Democrats and
liberals that we saw during the January
6th committee hearings right it's the Q
Anon stuff it's kind of that right
well um speaking of people who are
worried about January 6th it sounds like
Laura Ingraham is a little concerned
about everyone getting their cell phones
seized uh she had this lawyer uh you've
done a couple tweets about him here
he's a [ __ ] idiot but he he's got the
shittiest legal takes maybe we should do
another uh this will definitely be an
episode but
um um this year this is on Laura
ingraham's show and they're talking
about they're talking about phones being
seized and Laura seems very concerned
that her phone might be seized I don't
know I'm just saying let's watch it it's
almost as if they're seizing phones of
anyone who might have communicated with
the president or anyone who's close with
the president she seems a little
concerned here about if she because
remember yeah we saw the January 6
select committee um out Sean Hannity and
Laura Ingram here text not the president
but Mark Meadows about hey you're
destroying our reputation so she knows
how to communicate with the guy who
she's concerned that could cause maybe
her electronic device to be seized is
that what you're getting here that's the
bye-bye I mean that's exactly what I'm
picking up you would think here's the
thing you would absolutely think that
these [ __ ] boneheads would understand
why they're getting their phone seized
and their houses legally searched like
at a certain point after observing all
these other people who are like oh we
found out they committed this crime or
they were doing this illegal thing or
they were doing this you would think at
a certain point they'll go oh yeah you
know what this makes total sense while
they took my stuff but no they can't
because they're like we are the hero of
this story we're not the villain we're
the ones who are trying to repair and
restore democracy but we're actually
trying to [ __ ] steal it you know
right it's Monday night wrestling and
we're the good guy wink but listen to
the listen to the take that this guy
follows up with Laura's just frightened
question here let's listen because it oh
it's a shitty legal take for sure
am I out on the limb here or what this
is scary stuff Laura we started out
where they were going after Trump for
non-crimes of keeping his presidential
records at Mar-A-Lago okay okay
so this guy goes on Fox News Mike Davis
is his name yeah Mike Davis not
surprising that Mike date you know I
mean Mike Davis as there are like this
is he also worked he also worked for
Gorsuch too oh did he really well yeah I
think he was right yeah yeah what the
[ __ ] is article three project president
article 3 project is his group his
organization oh wow and they they are
one of these right they got great hot
takes too
lots of hot takes yeah if you look at
their [ __ ] but it's uh it's it's just an
organization that he created that he's
the founder I believe uh and they come
in and they you know they do consultant
uh consultant kind of services for
different people who commit crimes to
try to PR yeah I mean like it's them
crimes right you know formulating the
legal argument around why some rights
should be taken away from someone you
know it's hilarious that you have to
have probable cause to take these things
now regardless of what the investigation
actually you know the fruit that bears
the investigation rather it's an
indictment a conviction a prison
sentence whatever you actually have to
have probable cause now we know that law
enforcement is good about
um you know making a probable cause but
this guy is going a bit too far when
he's saying the things that that he's
saying about
non-crimes like I love how he says non
guys it wasn't a big non-crime it's a
crime look no there were no crimes
committed it's fine you know right
non-currents let's let's listen uh now
they're going after his his supporters
they're going after supporters for
apparently the non-crime of questioning
an election you have to have a predicate
crime in order to have grand jury
subpoenas and warrants which that's what
they have
that's what they got dude dude doesn't
even realize that yeah and the [ __ ] is
actually coming from does he think they
[ __ ] make this [ __ ] up in the kitchen
or something before they walk dude I'm
telling you like when we were talking
with Jeff earlier this is this honestly
reminds me of uh National Treasure it's
this idea that they have to take the
thing commit the crime to avoid the
other person from taking the thing or
committing a crime and this is an
example right here was like well I had
to had to justify getting this uh
getting people to ask the question of
whether it's a fair election but by
doing so we had to commit a crime to
make question of whether it was a fair
election and that is the argument that
they're trying to create is like look we
had to commit it to show it was broken
for you to guys look at and say Hey look
it's broken right and it wasn't everyone
unless you broke it it's the same thing
where they break [ __ ] intentionally and
then they they they have a Band-Aid
fixture like look we fixed it a little
bit all right there was a problem that
we created and we all right we fixed it
right let's let's continue with this hot
take from Mike generic Davis
what's the crime they're investigating
questioning the election we're not a
third world
um
what is this third world [ __ ] they
keep trying I don't know they just it's
just the buzzwords it's just like how
many how many [ __ ] freak out you know
manga King buzzwords can we throw it's
almost like they're going to his his
fraud social post to figure out how to
write these scripts it really is [ __ ]
it is it is a jungle of of uh of just
buzzwords for sure I mean they're it's
just Trump buzzwords where he says Mark
says socialist third world hell hole
leftist laptop from hell like all of
those things you just throw them into a
blender and then this guy's like yeah
let me throw a couple legal words around
these and I think I've won over the
audience good we'll make it good we'll
make it good I mean we'll make it the
goodest for sure right the goodest of
ever and the good and good in history of
ever ever ever was Jesus [ __ ] Christ
speaking of
boneheads in the history of ever ever
was here's lady G Lindsey Graham
yesterday you know you pointed out
something earlier he's the white dude
standing in front of a a line of women
talking about how he if you just elect
him and the Republicans and you put them
in power how he is going to take away
your freedom let's listen to this
nonsense so I'll look forward to the
debate I look forward to the vote if we
take back the house and the Senate I can
assure you we'll have a vote on our bill
that the Democrats are in charge I don't
know if we'll ever have a vote on our
bill so there it is there it is folks
the only reason you need to go vote is
that if the Republicans take back power
in the Senate and the house they will
take away your freedom that's what they
want that's what they're campaigning on
and if the Democrats get elected they
will codify your freedom and make sure
that you have it from now until the end
of time
there's a difference your choice is
autocracy or democracy here
it's just absolutely flabbergasting that
Lindsey Graham walked straight into this
or is or am I just off my [ __ ] no I
mean like he walks straight up said as a
white man who's never experienced any of
these things that a woman will and says
hey well you know what I think we should
have a national Band You know despite
again when we talked to Jeff earlier in
the show he was like yeah this is all a
state's right issue is what they were
debating and saying it should be and now
they're saying this should actually be a
national ban so again Republicans will
go back on their word contradict be
Hypocrites project that is the Playbook
that they go by and they look at
themselves as oh no we're we're the ones
who fix the problem right like give us
the right to to rule over you and we
will remove your rights is basically the
the party platform of the Republican
party right now
one more thing before we go and I
mentioned it in the first a block before
we go to Michael Cohen because after the
break here we're going to bring on
Michael Cohen uh the former attorney of
Donald Trump and I'm gonna ask him we're
gonna ask him about that DC trip to the
golf course what the secret meeting was
about what he thinks that meeting was
about but also we're going to ask him
about Berman and his book tour and how
he's making these accusations I'm going
to find out more about that but um JoJo
from she's a friend of the show here she
went to the White House yesterday there
was pictures of her with with the
president uh Joe Biden it didn't seem
like he was dark Brandon at that point
it was out in the daylight so right
right because he kind of switches back
and forth between dark he had the
sunglasses on so you couldn't see the
laser I see I see what it is well if you
want speaking of dark Brandon if you
want some dark Brandon merch to go to
store.thetonymichaels.com get your dark
Brandon t-shirts hoodies coffee mugs and
stickers and gave these dark Brandon
shirts are flying off they shelves
Everyone likes this exclusive design we
have here for these dark Brandon shirts
don't miss our design yeah you want to
wear that everywhere but Joe says here I
guess my description of how Joe Biden
smells triggered crackhead snowflakes
confession I had been drinking literally
Newsweek wrote a story about how she
tweeted
that Joe Biden smelled because someone
asked her under the picture this is what
Newsweek is following up on here as our
democracy is burning as Jeff said I
don't understand this now I'm just
pointing this out because Joe is a
friend of the show in the last
commercial we played uh trucker Convoy
Joe wrote that commercial she or she
wrote that script
um you do the intro you edited it and I
do the I do Bob she does Tammy
um but so I we're Joe is a friend of the
show here and we love Becky Sue Becky
sue the character that Joe does has been
on the show in the satire form
but Gabe can can you tell me is this
[ __ ] what what are they doing what
what are they don't know I well I think
they have obviously with everything they
have a difficulty of understanding what
is like she's making she's like oh yeah
he smelled nice right but she is going
to exaggerate it as part of a thing to
be like oh he smelled like hot cocoa
when you're sitting in front of a
fireplace and it's snowing outside and
the kids are running around the house
having fun there's you know Joy of Buzz
and all this stuff like she's giving
detail to add to the joke which is he
doesn't smell like [ __ ] like Trump right
because that's what she's getting and
she's saying oh he smells good right
well it's easier like makes me warm and
safe that there's like a normal decent
which that's a [ __ ] low bar yeah
normal decent person with empathy at the
head of our state which is crazy which
is crazy because the exact opposite is
we have the Cheeto dust mobster Grandpa
poopy pants Donald Trump himself
apparently apparently Gabe we want we
watch some video of him maybe having
secret meetings on a golf course in DC
there was big Fanfare when he landed no
golf club PC no golf clubs he had golf
shoes on when he landed some people
thought he was being arrested indicted
some thought maybe he was going to
Walter Reed but it seems like he was
having meetings on the golf course and
we're going to talk to Michael Cohen
Donald Trump's former attorney about
that and not only that but about Berman
and Michael Cohen's new book coming out
revenge so stick around everyone right
after this break we have Michael Cohen
coming right up so don't go anywhere
we'll be right back with Michael Cohen
right after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show thanks for for
sticking through the break
very special guest
today is gonna give us some insight
hopefully on this uh DC Golf Course trip
to Virginia but he's also going to talk
about uh Berman and Gabe I gotta show
you this tweet from Michael Cohen he
says he says here uh he says many are
asking me why Mr mushroom butter was
that his DC golf course which is really
in Virginia he says to play golf my
sources say he was meeting with two
lawyers in secrecy and didn't trust
being in their offices probably because
of like recording devices notice there
are no golf clubs on the on the cart so
he pointed this out uh in this picture
and you see here the Cheeto dust mobster
running around the golf course
in golf shoes mind you engulf a tire if
that's what you call this with no gold
what was he golfing with I don't know
let's let's do this there's actually
another photo I want to get uh uh
Michael's uh feedback you know but yeah
sure well let's let's do this let's
bring in Michael Cohen Michael how are
you hey Tony how are you oh I'm doing
great I'm doing great my friend
listen there's a lot of fanfare of why
he landed in DC everyone is speculating
that night it was late at night a lot of
people didn't have the information they
didn't know why he was there I believed
certain things at the time because
Donald Trump really doesn't go anywhere
without the red carpet rolled out right
so I knew that there was something afoot
so tell us about when you heard the news
that he landed in DC when there was no
real fan Fury had golf shoes on
everyone's like what the hell is going
on what's your first initial thought
when you when you watch that video okay
so we need to refer to him with his
proper name and that's Mr mushroom
putter all right uh that's that's to
start of course that's a combination of
his golfing Acumen and his sexual
relationship with Stormy Daniels all
right just in case your your followers
your viewers uh were unaware but I
didn't I refused to comment and so many
different people had asked me you know
what do I think was going on here why
was Trump there you know I saw him uh
Sheriff's vehicle I saw
um you know other people outside of
secret service and I didn't want to
start to speculate because at the end of
the day a lot of people who did
speculate looked very stupid
um why was he there my sources told me
that he didn't want to go to meet with
two lawyers regarding a and I don't know
which case it is considering he's got a
slew of them right now so they he didn't
want to go to their offices because he
didn't want people to know that he was
in DC and that
um you know he was there at a law firm
which of course in his mind uh
automatically implicates him again in
something and so he would he wanted to
have it's almost like a power play very
much like what he did or tried to do
with Tish James by having the Secret
Service claim that going to Tish James
office downtown would pose a security
risk for him uh so he likes things on
his own terms he didn't get it with the
attorney general here in New York but
when you're paying your lawyers Assuming
he's even paying it's okay to get them
to come out to Virginia to his Trump
National D.C Golf Course to see him to
talk about obviously a strategy
well I've got a picture here that Gabe
has shown us and here it is he's doing
that Gabe hey good at so here's the
picture Michael of them on the golf
course and they got some Flags no golf
clubs it looks like maybe some grounds
people I don't know if they're like
plotting out another burial site or
something where he can bury more
documents but what what the hell is
going on here I tried to tell this to
people all the time the Trump
organization was not Mafia Inc there was
no killings and hidings of bodies and
fairing them in Central Park or on a
golf course so on so if we can also add
that picture back in if the people can
still see me so let me sort of walk you
through obviously you see Donald right
there you see the tall guy to his right
in the picture that's Eric Trump you see
the little guy next to Eric that's
Lawrence Glick Larry Glick runs golf at
the Trump organization rest assured one
of these guys is probably Secret Service
that would be probably the guy in in
white considering he looks like he's in
good shape but the rest of the guys
especially the one holding the golf
course markers the guy is is he's not
looking to figure out where they're
going to bury somebody like Michael
Cohen you know or maybe moving ivana's
body from Bedminster to Washington DC
because it's a better view of the moment
that's not what's happened they're
probably talking about in my estimation
Trump is losing the ability
thanks to Mayor Eric Adams to use the
Trump Golf Course the lynx golf course
in Ferry Point which is in Yonkers for a
live golf tournament that's probably
what's happening they're trying to
figure out you know where to go what to
do now let me say this to you also
Donald Trump likes an audience that
should be nothing new to you nothing new
to your viewers he likes an audience so
he got everybody there the groundskeeper
he got the general manager he has his
son there Larry Glick blah blah blah and
they're all standing there listening to
this talmud Hassam right which is a
Yiddish word for a genius amongst
Geniuses pointing out where he wants to
move a [ __ ] Flag to or where he wants
to move you know or the the hole in the
great who knows what he was talking
about because they all look [ __ ]
bored out of them all right it's just it
is what it is they're all sitting there
especially the guy in the purple at the
end right he's like oh God can somebody
talk to me I can't listen to this [ __ ]
anymore right I mean he looks as
disinterested as we all are in the Mike
Lindell taking of his phones the poor
bastard all right I mean that's that's
really the truth and so no this is not a
group of Mafia guys figuring out
anything they're just a group they're a
group of half-wits including the former
president trying to figure out where to
move a tea box that's about what this is
all about and the reason that Donald
likes the big audience is because there
are members that are going to be playing
through and so of course because
Donald's there and they're still members
of his eponymous golf course and a bunch
obviously of stupid sycophantic maggots
what are they doing they're setting it
up so that he looks like he's busy and
important so that these people who post
this crap right see Donald with a slew
of people around them you probably could
have done this with just the guy holding
the flags you know the uh the team
markers
right you see them there in the in the
uh the maroon or red red shirt uh
Michael
because I looked at this picture and I
was like uh these don't look like
Mobsters to me it really looked like to
me either he was saying where he wanted
to move a body uh that is at Bedminster
or he was like I can't hit this hole
good enough can we move it closer can we
move it closer so I look better because
we know he cheats in golf so what would
be the difference did you ever see
there's a video out there of trump
standing on obviously one of his courses
on a t uh and they asked him uh oh Mr
President Mr President though he's not
the president how many times have you
had a hole in one in your life and you
know what this lying sack of [ __ ] says
seven
seven times he's hit hole in once right
it's just not true right and the
funniest then they asked Eric Trump how
many have you hit and he goes yeah I
haven't had one yet I haven't been lucky
enough I mean the guy will lie about
anything I mean it's truly incredible
that he has no there's he has no
compunction not to lie regardless of how
irrelevant it is do you really care
right if you have a hole in one or not
is your name going up on some sort of a
plaque you know um you know somewhere
other than in one of you golf course
bathrooms well he might make one he
might make one he might make one I mean
he didn't put himself on Time Magazine
right so well that is true at least once
right well so
and by the way he happens to be the
greatest lover in or in all of the the
world just sure you know
ask Marla uh who attested to that in the
New York Post yeah oh my God uh Michael
so I want to get back a little bit to
these two lawyers because I think I
think the distraction of him you know
figuring out if he's going to be able to
have the Saudis at this golf course
because he gave him all these classified
documents possibly and you know he's got
to receive his payment somehow maybe I
don't know I'm just I'm just snowballing
there
um
what about the two lawyers make
significance that he's in this at this
golf course that's so close to DC what
do you think is the significance because
it feels like to me when you did because
you did a video that you put around on
social media about this it feels like
there is some significance in that at
least I know we're joking about you know
him standing here with a bunch of
buffoons you know trying to Mark where
he can be better at golf but really at
the heart of this what do you think the
the lawyers meeting close to DC what do
you think the significance of that is
yeah it probably has to do with either
interrogatories that he is required to
respond to possibly even a subpoena but
again you know I hate these
hypotheticals and that's one of the
things the damaging things that Trump
has done to this country more so almost
than anything he's made a second guess
every single thing that's happening
whether it's the doj whether it's
Congress yeah it doesn't make a
difference he makes a second guess and
all of these high hypotheticals the the
number of of emails and text messages
and tweets and you name it asking me
about this group of schlemiels that are
standing there and why what you know
it's to me again it's making us double
think our lives and the fact that our
government is there to service so I
believe that it's probably and again I
hate these hypotheticals but as I did
say it on my tweet my source told me
that he then later in you know in the
day met with two lawyers uh probably
lawyers that are working on one of the
plethora of cases that are now uh
confronting him
well and I think that's that's important
too is that
um at a time where you know and and
that's what that's what I took from the
landing of him in DC like a time where
he's under so many investigations and I
would play the video of Sean Hannity
giving us every single investigation
that he's under on Fox News which was
incredible by the way that that was
incredible it was incredible that he
would just be like hey you want to know
how many crimes Trump is being
investigated for here's a whole list and
it's what you should have said there
Tony is these are the crimes that Trump
is actually guilty of but he hasn't been
charged yet with all of them he's
already been charged with obviously the
tax evasion bank fraud misrepresentation
and so on by um our attorney general
Tish James the Trump organization goes
to trial uh in October regarding uh the
same exact the same exact thing the
inflation of his net worth and the
deflation of the assets for tax purposes
and that's by um started by by side
Vance and now being continued by Alvin
Breg you also have coming up and I
believe it may even be tomorrow you have
um Tom Barracks case uh which has to do
with the Presidential Inaugural
Committee as well as other
um you know matters that he's being
looked into I mean every single one of
those we all know in our in the pit of
our stomach that Donald is guilty of
these but yet somehow the Teflon Don
this you know this snake in the grass
has managed to escape or not so much as
Escape as to delay the prosecution very
much like what he's trying to do with
the marlardo raid where they came and
they took documents again as a as a
former lawyer considering I was
disbarred for him you know getting his
pecker pulled by a porn star
what what is What's Happening Here is
it's amazing that he and even the judges
Eileen Cannon believe that Donald Trump
can declare privilege over stolen
documents that don't belong to him I
mean if you're not scratching your head
and saying what the [ __ ] seriously so
it's almost like I would go into a bank
steal money and then I would say before
I turn the money over to you or you're
allowed to take the money from me
I want you to identify every single
serial number and the fact that I didn't
say that it's not all mine I'm just
saying that some of it is mine and
therefore I'm entitled to withhold the
money back I mean it's just that stupid
and how they managed to get away with it
I don't know but what's worse is that it
could potentially delay
um the case even further and knowing the
way Trump likes to do it considering I
was involved in creation of that
Playbook he's going to try to look to
delay this thing for like a year but
fortunately you know we have uh an
excellent excellent Congress member who
heads the house oversight committee and
I'm referring to Carolyn Maloney now
Carolyn Maloney put forth yesterday a
document demanding that narrow which is
the
uh National Archives that they send
Trump a letter and in that letter was
the fabulous you should go and look for
it it was a letter to Nara from Carolyn
Maloney on behalf of the house oversight
committee to which she chairs stating
that she and the committee want Nara to
send a letter to Trump demanding that he
under oath and pursuant and subject to
the penalties of perjury
file a document an affidavit stating
that there are no additional documents
in his possession that he is unaware of
the location of any documents on
off-site locations as well as the fact
that he is unaware of anyone else who
may have seen or have possession of
these classified documents now he's not
going to sign that no matter what which
of course implicates him otherwise why
would you not sign it look I would sign
it I know I never gave any of these top
secret documents to anyone I've never
shown them because I've never had
possession the fact that he probably
would not do that would really be an
indication that he you know that he has
done it and now we have to find out what
actual documents are missing from those
multitude of top secret folders that
when opened were empty here's that uh
here's that story here chairman
chairwoman Maloney asked Nara to assess
missing presidential records from former
president Trump he keeps saying this
this presidential records act like this
presidential records Act is the thing
that's going to protect him but it's
actually the the law that he broke or
one of them well you also have him and
you know TV lawyer Jim trustee on TV
saying article two article two guys
Article 2 gives him all the power we're
actually going to be looking into
articles like they keep saying it but
it's like that is not what Article 2
gives you as a present in terms of power
that that is no I mean but it's typical
Trump to be like look if I say it enough
times then it's true right like if I
posted enough times on true social or
post it on Facebook or or wherever for
other people to post it becomes true
right and you have sure but then you
have Alina Haba out there and if you can
find that clip that's probably one of
the best I've ever seen so Alina Hobb is
up they're basically stating that Donald
Trump despite the fact he is not the
president any longer has absolute
um immunity he has executive privilege
and that he is absolute immunity from
any prosecution and that he was entitled
to do what he wanted because well first
of all he Declassified every document
which we know is not true considering
there's a process that goes on and
nobody other than Donald Trump himself
because remember there were probably
three people there right um and if
you're Donald it's like me myself and I
attesting to the fact that yes I did say
it just ask me and I will tell you and
it's unbelievable the guy truly he's
nuts because many smart people have
heard me say it
is he talking about me myself and I are
those people many people are saying many
people exactly I I Declassified I had to
classify doctors that I stole that I
shouldn't have even had I mean you know
I'm allowed to do that I have total I
have total power I'm the king I mean
that's really the problem folks is the
fact that the guy legitimately didn't
see himself as the 45th president of the
United States He Saw himself as this
Monarch or this king and you know that's
legitimately what he wants and the
saddest the saddest of these maggots
that is still running around
believing that Donald is really the
president and he's pulling the strings
of Joe Biden I mean some of these people
really should be you know um put into a
psych ward because if you could truly
believe that it's hard to imagine what
these people actually doing that they
have to interact with the public well
you know back to the president King
thing because
um you've been speaking out against uh
Berman and um I think this story is kind
of getting shuffled to the to the side
here but you're trying to bring it to
the Forefront
um tell us about Berman's book and what
he's saying and really what what is
coming out of the sdny it seems strange
well I guess not with Bill Barr and
Donald Trump the president King the
manga King as it were but tell us about
what's going on over there okay so
actually I cover this topic in
tremendous detail I have a book that's
coming out on October 11th and in fact
yesterday I got the first I got the
first book uh it's the first one off the
assembly line so they sent it to me the
rest are now in shipment over to Amazon
Barnes and Noble and various other I'll
show it to you I was so I'm so happy
yeah yes I well I made that I made the
graphic version if anyone wants to go to
Revenge Dash the book.com we've got the
link in the in the in the description
there too you can go to Amazon wherever
you buy your books but I do this in
great detail now let me just jump into
Jeffrey Berman for a second the book is
[ __ ] I don't even know what nice to
wait to say as it relates to me first
and foremost as I have been saying all
along that the southern district of New
York who called themselves The Sovereign
District of New York they act in a
manner which is really inconsistent with
law the problem though is that they are
the law it's their baseball field it's
their bad it's their ball it's their
plates right and it's there it's it's
their team and so you're basically a
loner and that's what happened you know
especially to me when I tried I never
knew what they were charging for they
raided my property
um you know they took 10 million
documents from me right I was given by
judge um Jones who is also up for
potentially being the special master in
Trump's case on Mar-A-Lago which would
be interesting I was given 40 days to go
through 10 million documents and I did
it in less than that so you could
imagine that the 11 000 documents that
Trump you know has to go through to D
you know to claim is not client
attorney-client privilege should be very
very easy it should take no more than a
week okay going back to Jeffrey Berman
first of all why he recused himself he
doesn't really tell the truth on that
Berman's brother had a relationship with
David pecker and they used David pecker
in order to testify against me to a
grand jury
um despite the fact that they obviously
knew of the relationship between uh
Jeffrey Berman's brother and David
pecker uh as had something to do with
George magazine and I believe Michael
Berman is actually Jeffrey Berman's
brother
point in fact it goes on and then you
have all of this in you know
interference by Bill Barr who in essence
is Jeffrey Berman's boss
being told by the Attorney General Bill
bars boss Donald Trump that we want to
have these matters reversed uh even
after the plea which I was forced to
take the plea and all of this by the way
folks is in the sentencing memo that I
gave to the judge who didn't give a [ __ ]
judge William H Paulie III he didn't
care the prosecutors knew it and they
wanted to bury it and they didn't care I
gave them the documents I gave them
everything showing unlike manafort I
never had money overseas fake invoices
and all of this is covered in incredible
detail including documents that just
that demonstrate that what they did is
they put a gun to my head and said on a
Friday at 5 30 PM if you don't plead
guilty to what we tell you to plead
guilty tomorrow right because even they
didn't know we're filing an 85-page
indictment and we're gonna include your
wife and when I found out what they were
going to get my wife for
when Trump was paying me back the 35 000
per month for the work that I you know
for the outlaying the money with Stormy
Daniels and some other things
I was the subject second time of
um identity theft and we knew who the
guy was I had pictures of him
the FBI the secrets that everybody was
looking they all knew where he lived
nobody grabbed him yet which made no
sense to me so what happens is we froze
all of my personal accounts just the guy
was running around with a driver's
license a New York driver's license with
all of my information on it uh and his
picture and he was cleaning out my bank
accounts I think he took like eleven
thousand dollars that until we shut it
all down so instead
um what happened is I gave my wife the
checks that would come in and she would
deposit it into the account that I took
my name off of that had her name only so
they were going to indict her as a
co-conspirator to the hush money
payments now I'm married 28 years love
this woman with all my heart and there
was no way I was gonna let these
bastards from the southern district of
New York There's Tom Mckay Nick Roos
Andrea Griswold the whole bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] that they are no way I
was gonna let them go after my wife
handcuff her process that's her take her
downtown that [ __ ] was not gonna happen
and so I said all right just tell me
what you want me to plead guilty to in
fact if you want me to plead guilty I
can close out the Lindbergh baby
kidnapping by you know or the Lufthansa
Heist by taking responsibility for that
too when they said to me well we don't
find you funny and I said I don't
[ __ ] find you guys funny either in
fact anyone who ever threatened my wife
other than somebody sitting there with a
badge inside of a courthouse I would
knock the [ __ ] out of you you scumbags
but lo and behold they work with the
judge the system is so [ __ ] corrupt
and I talk about it at great detail in
fact on page 95 of the book I talk about
it
um you know this is just one part the
U.S attorney's office there has a long
notorious history of being independent
in fact sdny has said to stand for The
Sovereign District of New York by many
criminal defense attorneys this by the
way is not meant as a compliment but
rather an attack on the way they conduct
themselves they act in a manner that is
completely independent from any judicial
body which is why Trump attempted to get
Jeffrey Berman the head of the Criminal
Division there to resign which he
refused the question needing to be asked
is why would the president of the United
States be so focused on this one facet
of the justice department other than for
the reason that it was the court
Prosecuting my case all right that's the
only reason that they wanted it he
wanted to reverse two charges the
campaign Finance violations which would
then go ahead remove him from any
accountability as what I deem to be
co-conspirator number one right
therefore he can say everything that
Michael Cohen is doing
is designed to get him a lesser sentence
at my expense and that all of the
illegalities that Michael did has to do
with his tax issue which by the way and
it's also part of the book something
that I talked about at length at my in
the uh in the in the sentencing document
as well as on television I I have never
filed a late tax return in my life I
have never not paid taxes in fact I've
never been audited in my life never had
an overseas bank account never had an
overseas invoice nominee any of the
items that would constitute you know
what's called tax evasion was there a
taxo mission yes there was whose mistake
was it it's my accountants I would give
him three ring notebooks tabulated with
every single bank statement showing
every single deposit I want to go one
step further because I talk about this
in Revenge as well and I certainly I I
write the book not because I'm trying to
exonerate myself I did my time I've lost
everything from my family's happiness to
more money than I even care to disclose
but nevertheless what I want to prevent
is this [ __ ] happening to anybody
else all right this should never have
happened in fact judge rinkoff who you
know talks about this all the time also
acknowledges and I have quotes from him
in the book acknowledges that the system
is broken and that there are significant
changes that need to be made to ensure
that no other narcissistic sociopath
president wannabe dictator can ever do
to anybody ever again and I believe that
all of these prosecutors instead of
going from their jobs as prosecutors
going to like the million dollar jobs at
Lowenstein Sandler McDermott oil and
Emery uh Davis Pope Paul Paul Weiss
Guggenheim Partners right they should
not be interested in their prosecution
rate but rather in their success rate
but rather in Prosecuting cases not
convictions and that's really what the
book does it's in order to open up
people's eyes so what happens when you
have somebody like a Donald Trump and
there are others like him like Ron
DeSantis all right who could be even
worse this is what happens when a
president weaponizes a justice
department against his critics so what
what Jeffrey Berman's book did it
validated this it validates this what he
did in order to go after his critics
well Michael
um you got the fire on today and that's
what I that's why I had you on because I
knew you'd have the fire you'd had the
fire about the the golf course you'd had
to fire about the the book and the
Berman case and really about the sdny
and what's going on there and more about
the corruption um that is deep-seated in
Donald Trump and like him I I have one
question I want to ask you that I've
been wanting to ask you for a long time
because Donald Trump's uh it seems like
he's trying to make this overturning row
and him selecting these Supreme Court
Justices is a great thing
um and in private he seems like it he
thinks it was a mistake they went way
too far with Lindsey Graham we we
watched the video earlier of Lindsey
Graham but here's the thing here's the
question I want to ask and I and I told
myself if I ever had you on the show
this would be a question I'd ask you
because we know now about the hush money
payment obviously uh with Stormy Daniels
this is played out you've been talking
about it um in the sdny and the
prosecution uh you going to prison and
paying the price for possible crimes
that Donald Trump committed as well
um but let me ask you do you know about
the payments by Trump to pay for
abortions we know he's paid for hush
money payments but do you know about the
payments that Donald Trump has made for
abortions no uh and in fact I don't
believe that he did at least certainly
not in my tenure that was there
um it's just it's just not true
um you know I don't know why that that
is another question that constantly
comes up I think the real question that
people should be considering when they
look at Trump is whether or not he
actually is pro-choice or he's pro-life
and the answer is he is pro-choice why
because he doesn't give a [ __ ] what you
do he doesn't care about you this is a
guy that wouldn't cross the street with
a bottle of water to put you out of if
you were on fire because he doesn't give
a [ __ ] for God's sakes and people have
to understand you know what he did is he
used what was important to the white
Southern Christian Coalition the
Evangelical group and others he he used
what was important to them so that he
could start to amass a base that would
support him both as far as the votes as
well as monetarily and it's the same
group of idiots that are out there right
now giving him hundreds of millions of
dollars to a pack that they never even
read the fine print on which of course
most people don't read five print but
when it comes to Trump you got to read
everything he is entitled to 90 of every
dollar 90 cents on every dollar to use
at his discretion so folks do you know
what that means that means that he's
keeping 90 cents of every dollar that
you donate and that's it's I mean it's
truly a a disgraceful thing for a former
president to do you know most former
presidents they go out in style in class
they go to other countries they help
with the cause Donald Trump Trump is
helping with a cause too it's called his
left pocket his right pocket it is it is
disgusting on every level and so what
did he end up doing in order to appease
this Evangelical white Southern
Christian Coalition they gave him a list
of judges who are all you know who all
think and behave exactly the same and
all believe that Roe v Wade should not
have been decided that it should be a
state's right
um it's just the beginning of the
problems thanks to now a lopsided
Supreme Court
well I appreciate the answer there
Michael and and playing ball with me on
that question because I wanted to ask
you for a long time uh do me a favor um
give us give us the best pitch you got
for your book one more time uh before we
go yeah look the book Revenge I believe
like disloyal uh is truly it's a must
read and I I ask people just to go to
Revenge hyphenthebook.com read the
forward and the afterword very
interesting by the way the afterward
um I didn't write the forward I wrote uh
the afterword is written by uh Norm
Eisen uh as well as by Dania Perry and
so I think you'll find it very
interesting but what it does is it's a
forensic analysis that takes you from
the very very beginning which was the
fake uh allegations of me uh in the
steel dossier I've never been to Prague
and the number of journalists that got
that wrong because it benefited them all
the way to the unconstitutional remand
against me
um for refusing to wave my first
amendment constitutional right making me
the first political prisoner held in my
own country because I wouldn't waive my
constitutional right it takes you
through the entire scenario and shows
you exactly who was involved why they
were involved backed up with documents
and evidence and and um footnotes and so
on it is truly a read that I want people
at the end of the day to come and not
I'm not looking for people to feel sorry
for me or to pity me for what happened I
want to ensure that this never ever ever
happens again to anyone else and the
only way for that to happen is for
people like your viewers and so on to be
informed of exactly again what happens
when a U.S president a narcissistic
sociopath the orange crusted Mandarin
Mussolini himself elects to weaponize
the justice department using a willing
and complicit attorney general to go
after a Critic all right it's just not
what our founding fathers ever expected
you know but it happened and we all have
to be knowledgeable of it
well thank you Michael for joining us
everyone
um go out and grab your your pre-ordered
copy on Amazon or wherever you get your
books or you can go to
revengethebook.com Michael Cohen again
thank you for joining us sir we will we
will talk to you very soon come back and
come back and join us um after this uh
Trump organization trial if you would
and give us your insights uh well I'll
I'll stay in touch with you on that as
we as we watch that trial go on thank
you Michael for joining us everyone go
out and grab grab Michael's book uh Gabe
what a great interview with uh with
Michael Cohen he always brings the heat
he always brings the spicy holy moly
holy moly
um everyone it's been a great episode we
have Jeff tamaron we had Mike Lindell
and more fast food clown manga clowns
oh my God what was the day this is two
hours I mean we're over we're over time
right now but wow
yeah two great guests we had a quick
little shitless Roundup boom boom boom
and I wanna I wanna tell everybody the
sh the uh um the bone end of the week
pole is out because Gabe cannot join us
on Friday live so you gotta go vote now
go out and vote on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod follow us there while
you're voting for bone and Elite you can
also vote here on YouTube don't forget
to subscribe while you're on YouTube you
do not want to miss a thing we've been
putting out a ton of news Clips ton of
media Clips on our YouTube channel so
subscribe you don't want to miss that go
check out the media Clips uh playlist
there's also a what was that this
morning that dropped on our Channel and
on minus touch as well so go check out
that what was that there should be a
what was that on the Mike Lindell phone
seized at a Hardee's drive through boom
so don't forget to subscribe You're Not
Gonna Wanna Miss a Thing oh also go
download every single episode of the
Tony Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify
Google your favorite directories make
sure to leave us a great review while
you're there and subscribe don't forget
to do that
um also we've got these dark Brandon
shirts game they're flying off the
shelves Joni michaels.com make sure to
go get your exclusive Tony Michaels
podcast Dart Brandon shirt black red uh
heavy metal is the other is the other
color you can also get a hoodie fit it
very fitting you know you can like
probably very fitting size wise but also
fitting is in terms of the that's right
they need the color well we also have
coffee mugs if you want to drink your
dark roasted Brandon coffee uh you can
get your dark or you can just have a
sticker If you want to put it on like a
laptop or you know your car or something
slap it that's right so go to
store.the20michaels.com and get your
dark Brandon merch exclusive design
everyone come back tomorrow we will be
here a noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
same time same place
Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn had asked